we interrupt this program to bring you
Courage the Cowardly Dog Show abandoned
as a pup he was found by Muriel whales
in the middle of nowhere with her
husband Eustace Bagge
yeah but creepy stuff happens in nowhere
it's a stupid dog you made me look bad
[Music]
welcome back greatest show on the planet
oh yeah I was getting bad now voice
cracking crack included I guess first of
all I want to thank you brothers for
100,000 likes on Facebook that's a lot
of likes I really remember when I had
like 5,000 I was like yeah thousand felt
like a lot and then just I don't know
100,000 it came a lot sooner than I
thought it was it's pretty cool that's
pretty cool also I was the winner of
king of the way up a couple weeks ago
and I find fun element that I received
my hair the the money so I thought we'll
just snap into future pew pew and he
will donate the money and show you that
all right Thank You pity poem from the
path whatever alright so here's the
email where I received the money from
king of the web they are feelings job
there you go my name to my email is not
showing any way I would not want it to
be spammed
that's my skype is anyway that's the
first one apparently they take like a
30% cut for taxes which i think is kind
of weird I thought I'd paid my own taxes
not that they would actually do it and
you know just take the cut and here you
are so I made them about it and they
were like hey how come fast blah blah
cuz they said you
my mother and I only got this imagine
they were like alright so here we are on
roof comm I click donate make a one-time
donation and $6,750 and then max my
donations I don't need any of these then
I will fill in this end and I'll see you
in a second alright so here we are
thank you we appreciate this board of
WTF nerds were to say my life and white
thanks
that's that I want to thank you both
again I don't know if food in the past
said it or not but it really meant a lot
to me to win this competition and really
all the support everyone was showing
during that race it was really amazing
to see and I'm really glad a lot of
people weren't support his cause so to
everyone who voted and supported me
through this you're all part of donating
this amount and I'd it's really amazing
give yourself a brofist that wouldn't
look stupid and it's you know you're
awesome
yeah I'm really happy and thankful yeah
and we're back with the old appear
payout don't worry I'm still pretty good
even though I'm all I don't know what
I'm talking about
I thought we will do another challenge
slend
last challenge I did was cinnamon
challenge it was horrible this one is a
little more easy I think at least chubby
bunny challenge you take one of these
marshmallows as soon as I bring the
candy Maya wants to come Jack okay
alright so you put one in your mouth and
then to prove that you can do it you say
chubby bunny or choke something I have
evolved
all right that's one cow be jokes on
dicks god yes oh god yes like either I
don't even like mark on mine you have
another time
all right Chuck some Nick Nick
I lost pounds all those Rick all right
talkin there then ill that's disgusting
oh no I dropped them
[Music]
alright so that was pretty damn
disgusting if you don't want to try this
challenge out all you need is a pecan
for marshmallows or you can do it with
nut you probably shouldn't do it at all
but anyway whoever better quality beats
me I don't know a lot of stuff to do for
me these days I know someone commented
like you only recoge like 30 minutes
every day it can't be that hard but I
really do put a lot of time and work
into the YouTube thing it's it's a lot
more than meets the eye but iced I still
love doing it so I really do read most
of the comments and if you want because
you know the interaction between us that
sounded really good I there's no way in
hell that I would still like do these
videos like it's it's only because of
this this bromance we got going here
what I thought that's how I feel Italy
so I'm really I'm really good glad and
grateful like you brothers still enjoy
my videos I do my best to keep them
entertaining at least um you know I'm
it's really fun you know it feels more
real somehow you know that people see me
outside or whatever but it's something I
never ever ever ever expected to happen
but it really is a lot of fun and you
know I want to really thank you both for
everything you do and that's why you're
gonna end it with a breakfast now
there's a lot of you who do it every
week and I do appreciate it that
otherwise I feel really stupid but I
know there's just someone after sitting
there be like oh no here's the part
we're just gonna bro fit I'm just gonna
turn up the video little harder you know
ah too late
alright here we go one of those and
whatever okay here we go bras
stay awesome caramel activate
[Music]